today I'm going to share with you the
easiest way to have an instant impact on
someone I want to tell you a quick story
about a friend of mine named DJ duck
duck in the house digit duck has been
involved in Toronto dance salsa for a
number of years he's been a close
personal friends of mine he's came up to
my wedding he is an internationally
known DJ and producer I remember going
to Malaysia and I was offered to DJ at a
Malaysian club and I play the DJ duck
track and the DJ is there knew him and
they were they were freaking out that I
knew who duck was and had a personal
contact into him we do some kind of
legend over in Malaysia Tuesday's an
internationally known award-winning
Latin DJ and producer and ever since
I've known doc he's been a big guy he's
been overweight he's one of the first
guys to get one of my believe t-shirts
and it was like 2xl or 3xl and recently
had a health scare and he had the scale
back and a lot of the work that he was
doing to just focus on his house and
part of his path back the house was
walking and taking steps and he would
use his Samsung device attract his steps
and he was getting 20 or 25,000 steps a
day and I like using steps and I'm a
tracker I got my Fitbit on here and it
said doc join me on Fitbit will do we do
weekly challenges on pip pip with a
bunch of us Joe me on Fitbit and
eventually he did he joined our group
and in the first day he went from
averaging 20 to 25,000 steps a day to
hitting 30 thousand steps a day the
first time that he ever hit 30,000 steps
a day in his life happened on the first
day of our challenge but it didn't stop
there he then went to 35,000 steps and
forty thousand steps then fifty thousand
steps and then 60 thousand steps because
I was pushing it because I was in the
same competition i'm getting my steps on
we're both walking and challenging each
other and here's a guy who went from
twenty to twenty-five thousand steps a
day which is still way better than
average like the most the average person
takes five to ten
thousand steps a day if they're lucky
and here he was doing 20 25 but nobody
was pushing him to do more suddenly he
joins the group and he's hidden up to
60,000 steps a day which before for him
would have been a crazy goal but it
happened because I was in the group
pushing him and leading by example since
duck has been on this health kick he's
dropped from a size 42 to a size 34 in
waist and he's still going to get
healthier and healthier and healthier so
the lesson here for you guys if you want
to have an immediate instant impact on
someone else it's not just telling them
what to do is I'm saying hey Doc you
should go walk since 2000 steps I think
would be good for you rights I've just
given advice it's being there with them
it's leading by example it's being a
model for somebody look I'd say I want
to do with that person doing I want that
results that they're getting be that
person who's with them that they look up
to and inspired to be that want to have
a positive impact on their life now duck
was so moved and motivated by this
challenge and decided to make a weekly
vlog talking about it sometimes he
mentions me my name sometimes he just
references me as his competitor and I
wanted to share a couple clips from his
vlog that I think irrelevant to this
video DJ duck here I just came back from
a walk yeah me and DJ right there yeah
we were just walking for a couple hours
because I'm trying to win this Fitbit
work week hustle challenging homes in
it's a hard work cuz my competitor is
pretty competitive right so he's he
keeps going on top of me man so I gotta
push hard and see what I can come up
with you know i mean i'm back at the Pan
Am center stepping again yeah
trying to step as much as i can because
my my competitors stepping up on me
right mr. Evan he's taking the lead back
and forth I take the lead to yeah it's
just going it's one bonkers man we're
like neck the neck so we gotta we gotta
fix this you know I mean see we're gonna
be the winner so I gotta go keep
stepping right now and I'm still walking
it's nighttime as you can see trying to
beat my competitor and I am at the
bachata social at TDS right about now
and step in while I'm breaking Lee and I
mean because my competitors on top of me
again and I need to I need to get back
and retain number one timbits get over
here this yellow stop guys killing her
right now tell Evan I'm gonna come on
the provider have it there's gonna beat
you there i'm so I this is no joke
for real leaving tread marks or yeah
tell Evan what I'm doing walking around
tds yeah like the fielding non-stop yes
when I'm not dancing right yes when he's
not there yeah why jab you're such a
competitor and then I suggest that thing
he attaches to DJ but then he goes down
that shooting yeah I don't cheat man I
want to beat you fair and square
yesterday it was crazy man me and my
competitor doing the work week hustle
Fitbit step challenge we were going back
and forth man crazy almost did
fifty-five thousand steps yesterday but
couldn't get that badge because yeah I
was 300 like 300 fort and then a reset
up midnight so what can you do man but
hey what an accomplishment man I've
never done over 50,000 steps and I know
my competitor has done it for the first
time too because it's crazy man it's
crazy so two more days of this challenge
and yeah man I'm beat man you're putting
some putting some limits on my body mr.
competitor ha anyway and the work week
us all challenge her Fitbit is done and
I must say man
congratulations to Evan Carmichael man
you you killed it you definitely killed
it man I I tried my very best to compete
with you right on herself for a second
because I'm still proud of what I did
and proud of my accomplishments and
proud what a done man because you pushed
me to the Outer Limits you pushed me
beyond boundaries you pushed me the
things that I couldn't never even think
about achieving man so thank you bro
thank you for helping me out there man
and it feels great to be back on the
track just taking a leisurely today
because all week my body's been working
you know I mean so congratulations it
was a great competition man that I gave
it all I could do and
yeah man so fit full life and healthy
whole night and I'm saying so this is
good things man keep it up all right and
for all you people out there keep doing
a thing stay focused stay committed be
consistent most of all have fun doing
what you're doing and I'm saying all
right so without further ado I'm out
have a great weekend it's so again the
message comes back to if you want to
have a positive impact in somebody
else's life and make it an immediate
impact make them want to change
instantly then it's leading by example
model the behavior that you want them to
take and on the flip side if you want to
have an immediate impact on your life
then it's be around people who inspire
you right DJ doc would be Sid still
there his 20 to 25 k steps a day because
that was the best in his circle of
friends right anybody else is doing 5 to
10 day look at him said why are you
doing 25 that's awesome doc then he
joins in with us and I'm putting them to
do 60 now his circle has expanded so if
you want to get to that next level you
want to be instantly impact to make a
positive impact on your life then you
need to change you people you're hanging
around with change your environment as
well to make you become the best version
of yourself and push you outside your
comfort zone thank you guys so much for
watching the question I have for you
guys today is I'm really curious to find
out what you're trying to change in your
life right now whether it's a life thing
a business thing personal thing really
curious to find out what you're working
on where you want to challenge your
yourself a little bit grow take your
comfort zone leave it in the comments
below what I think sharing your store
can help inspire others to want to take
action as well and also help you know
you make a public notification what
you're trying to do you're more likely
to follow through because you've now
made that public so be courageous put it
down in the comments I'd also love to
see some support for Doc wishing well on
his journey
gradually on him success keep that
motivation fuel going for him for him to
reach his goal and stay on the track the
health so please leave a comment produc
below and also my goal right now on the
channels to hit a million subscribers so
anything you can do to share the video
let people know about it tell your
friends about the channel out of the
playlist tweet about it I really super
bottom I heart appreciate it thank you
guys so much for watching continue to
believe and I'll see you soon